6 24 on your wednesday morning if you're
complaining about headlights or
the lack of using them lyanna writes
please remind your viewers they must
turn
on their headlines at dusk not only is
it the law she writes but it's dangerous
to drive without him at night
she says that some drivers seem to be
under the mistaken impression that
daytime running lights in those newer
cars are okay but they are not
she writes most daytime running lights
do not provide tail
lights and she says until actual lights
are turned on a car can essentially be
invisible from the rear until brakes are
applied
she writes i've witnessed several near
accidents and i was almost in one of
them
well drivers consider yourself reminded
here's an idea you know how most cars
these days make a noise when you leave
the headlights on and you open the door
after you turn the car
off
yeah that sound here's an idea wouldn't
it be cool if the car could make that
same
noise when you start driving at night
and you have forgotten to turn the
lights on
huh leanna thanks for writing in now you
can find the online version of this and
all our stories at eight news now when
you click
traffic then driving me crazy buckle up
drive carefully please put on that phone
something's driving you crazy email me
traffic eight eight news now dot com